[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to PJ's C
class today we want to talk about how to
build a diamonds uh in Rhino 5 uh I
personally use Rhino gos and Matrix uh a
lot of time I just bring the Stone from
a library it's really convenient and
never thinking about how actually I need
to build it until students start asking
me so I think it's a good chance now to
talk about how to build this diamond in
the Rhino before we started we need to
take a look on the diamond structure and
actually
how um The Diamond C is actually cut the
stone so let's go to uh find some
resource
first there are a lot of good resource
online uh first I will go is the Gia
website uh in their website um there's a
articles talking about the stone and
actually give you a really brief about
what the part of the stone um how many
uh faces is that um very importantly I
mean because the stone is cuted in
differently based on you know the rough
and the stone color will decid it how
big what is the area but it give you a
good idea what is the perfect cut you
know what is the dimension the p uh
percentage of the part so Gia uh website
give you a lot of a good detail and a
clear drawing about you know house is a
stone supposed to be cut so I'm going to
use this image I also look at a lot of
uh tutorial um YouTube on other people's
website showing like how the stone is
cut how is holded it's quite interesting
uh I will suggest you look at those as
well but let's take a look how we
actually going to build this Stone in
Rhino they are specific uh name for the
stone we want to understand first so
let's take a look at the front view as
you can see I already name it here on
the one on the top this area SC table
and then uh Crown area this is the crown
area over there good is really important
is how is showing you how big is the
stone size and then you have Pavan and
then the CET is the really bottom this
is on the side view we have this front
table to kill it now let's take a look
on the top view you also have different
faces the one um the one I'm pointed
right here this one is actually the
table right next to the table you have
have this little triangle is called star
faces and then next to the star faces
you have a bezel facet okay so as you
can see it's all go by the numbers of
eight okay so this is really important
number eight so we're going to have
everything has eight uh ages or faces to
go with it so let's take a look um how
we actually going to build this one I'm
going to turn everything off and
starting from the
scratch based on the stone profile I
draw uh this uh green curve right here
as you can see it follow where the table
all the way to the culet um there
there's no there's a standard for this
one um and then if you follow the
perfect cut and then you will find you
know what is the best profile but in the
reality it really depends on the
inclusion of a stone maybe you have a
more pavilian maybe your girdle will be
thicker it's it's really depends on the
stone but we I'm using this profile for
building the Rhino uh
today first of all uh let's take a look
on the front view I would like to put
some single uh Point snapping to the end
point of those point and that give me a
good good reference that when I look at
the top view I know where they are okay
and then let's take a look on the top
view I'm going to use the polygon Tool
uh to creating a curve and that way I
can snaping into this um point I just
put it in there now I'm going to hold a
shift key so it will go like exactly
this way and I want to have that the end
point there is touching where close to
uh the second Point uh that I just
placed so I have this eight
faces curve over
there I'm going to copy this one with
the gumbo on holding the shift so you
will scale all the way um all three
Direction and tap the ALT key at LT so
you see the Press sign on my mouse and
then you release your mouse
and what I wanted to do is have this one
close to where half of the second and
the third point over there now because
what we my goal is trying to creating uh
those little triangle on the
top which is is the star faces um but I
need to do is to rotate this guy um
using the Gumball the rotate the second
curve for 22.5
de all right and next they are on the
same level as you can see the front view
so I want to move from the front view
going down to the roughly about half of
the girdle okay so now if you look at a
perspective I
have it's hard to see
okay just change the color so now you
can see I have two curve there next what
I'm going to do is make sure my all snap
end point is on and I'm going to snaping
into all those
point to create this star fa
it in fact you actually only need to do
one section which is one triangle and
then we're going to use the
polar array to array 360° I'm doing this
is because I want you to see the whole
structure okay so it might take a bit
longer but you will it was easier for
you to understand so now we have this uh
star facet we need to create another
one which is this bezel facet uh if you
look
at that uh this is what we are going to
create next this faces over there
okay now we need another octagon so I'm
going a curve so I'm going to pick up
the one on the table and again I'm going
to scale it again and to meet my third
point and hit t uh tap on the all key so
now I have the third curve I'm going to
go to the front view and move it close
to where that point is now if we look at
this I'm going to
hide the second octagon now in the
perspective you're going to see
something like this and again what we
need to do is kind of Link everything to
together so I'm going to go to
endpoint and make sure I hit the oon
endpoint and it just keep
going and
again I'm showing you the structure
that's why I'm creating the whole things
but you don't have to do the whole
things you just need to do one eight of
them all right okay now if we look at
the top view we we have this
octagon things but our Stone supposed to
be round so if you look at the stone
originally you're going to notice that
on the very last
one those faces marking in red color
here this one it's
called upper half faces as you can see
there's a two upper half faces and is
actually there are eight faces here okay
so if
our
octogon which has eight faces on the
single one here it should have eight
faces that means I'm going to create a
new
polygon and let's go back to the top
view let's create a new
polygon going to go to there and number
of a size typing
64 want to snapping into the end
point and then we want to snapping into
the the end point of that third oon we
created but make sure you look at all
view um you may you may if you just
click like that if you look at my front
view it might be um uh tilted so why we
want to turn on our smart tract and then
we we want to move it up
um move it up our Mouse so if you go to
the top view it's snapping into the end
and then you go into the front view and
then you kind of see this white uh line
showing up um then you want to move it
on the top view again and click so now
this
point the curve of M point will align
with that point on the
girle okay um but this one's actually
need to go down
here Point like that so now it look more
rounded we no longer need
this um the third one the third octagon
so we
have the basic Stone uh look like I
didn't going to move this back a little
bit to the end point to the end point
okay
now I'm going to create the faces on
those and I'm going to use the uh
polyline and snaping to the end point to
the end point and snapping this end
point to the end point so you notice
that I
have if you zoom in you can of see the
straight line there
so just going to be patient and oops be
patient and
click all of them and again you don't
have to do the whole thing you just need
to do one
section and then we're going to
use
the uh polar array I'm sorry okay now
let's look at all of this I'm going
to explore
explode all the curve so they no longer
like stick together all right let's
start creating the faces for the
triangle I'm going to do is using the
command for the surface you have a
surface from 2 3 4 hes curve so I'm
going to click on the H so I'll create
that face it and then I'm going to click
on the age
here curve curve curve so I have another
pH it and those triangle we just need to
be patient and click one by
one and
um I'm going to fast forward for
you all right it's done okay so now we
have this one section here we just need
to have it repeated oh I forgot one
little one okay so let me go
back click click and click all right so
we have that one section to select all
of them at once I'm going to go into
selection tool and I'm going to pick up
this uh select single surface so while
they are select let's go back to the top
view and we want to do polar array so
let's go to the uh array tool oops array
tool and then you got this polar array
here the center I will just type it zero
and the number is eight which is showing
right here so you type it eight and then
you want to make sure you got
360° okay so now we have all this faces
here so how we are going to do the top
right here uh it's quite easy you have
the command is called uh surface from
planer curve
so you're going to do the
curve and uh I should have it done this
before array everything but things
happen all right so I'm going to click
on all the
curve and hit enter now we have the top
portion is
done and uh I'm going to finish the rest
of it and my second video notice that it
might be a little bit FL out um I will
adjust that as well and show you on the
second video so thank you for watching
I'll see you on my other video
[Music]